[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ja entweder ist heute bei
ihnen Feiertag oder eben nicht und damit
einen schönen guten Abend Christian otto
ist mit mir im Studio hat später alles
Wichtige vom Sport sehr gern guten Abend
hier sind unsere Themen des Tages
Krisenhilfe für Bürger und Unternehmen
die Expertenkommission schlägt vor wie
sich Deutschland den dramatischen
Energiekosten entgegenstellen soll
neues Insolvenzverfahren Galeria
Karstadt Kaufhof muss erneut massiv
Stellen abbauen und sich verkleinern
und Lula hat es geschafft in Brasilien
löst der linke Herausforderer den
Rechtsextremen Präsidenten bolsonaro ab
[Musik]
worauf Millionen in Deutschland seit
vielen Wochen warten wurde heute
konkreter nämlich wie genau Entlastungen
für Haushalte und Unternehmen angesichts
der krassen Energiepreissteigerungen
aussehen könnten dazu präsentierte die
Expertenkommission heute ihre finalen
Vorschläge im Bundeskanzleramt schon
länger auf dem Tisch ist der Vorschlag
dass der Staat den Dezember Abschlag für
alle Gaskunden übernimmt ab kommendem
Jahr soll eine gaspreisbremse Haushalte
und Industrie entlasten neu ist für
Unternehmen soll es die Hilfen nur bei
einer Standortgarantie und einem
Kündigungsschutz geben außerdem ein Fond
für Härtefälle der auch für Besitzer von
Öl und Pelletheizungen gelten soll und
Kündigungsschutz für Mieter die ihre
energieschulden nicht sofort zahlen
können mattis Feldhoff berichtet
der Kanzler weist den Weg und damit
vielleicht auch die Unterschiede die
Experten links die Regierung rechts denn
ob die Vorschläge tatsächlich eins zu
eins umgesetzt werden wie von der
gaspreiskommission erarbeitet ist noch
offen noch in dieser Woche werden wir
Eckpunkte vorstellen wie die Vorschläge
der gastkommission umgesetzt werden
können genauso wie die strompreisbremse
das gaspreisbremse und strompreisbremse
schnell umgesetzt werden können im
finalen Bericht von heute werden die
gashilfen für Unternehmen an den Erhalt
von Arbeitsplätzen geknüpft außerdem
soll ein Sozialfonds eine gerechte
Verteilung sorgen die Vorschläge der
gaskommission schießen heute bei den
Sozialpartnern auf Zustimmung die die
gb-vorsitzende verweist nochmal auf die
besonders sozial Schwachen deswegen
freue ich mich darüber dass die
Kommission auch hier einen klaren
Vorschlag für ein entsprechenden
Hilfsfonds beschrieben hat der dann
hoffentlich auch genutzt wird und von
der Bundesregierung auch konkretisiert
werden kann wir brauchen dringen
Entlastungen für die Unternehmen damit
sie weiter produzieren können die
gestiegenen Preise können von den
Unternehmen nicht einfach in den Markt
weitergegeben werden für die Verbraucher
bleibt eine Lücke zwischen der
Einmalzahlung und dem Start der
gaspreisbremse es wird eine Notlösung
mit der Einmalzahlung vorgeschlagen da
sind immer noch viele Fragen offen und
die Fragen werden sogar mehr der ganze
Sommer wurde vertan und deshalb ist es
enorme Zeitdruck und die preisbremsen
kommen zu spät für diesen Winter in der
Analyse ist man sich zwischen Regierung
Gewerkschaften und Arbeitgebern recht
einig der Unterschied beginnt bei der
konkreten Umsetzung
und wir wollen Nachfragen bei chakunta
La bernergy in berlinischer kunterler
was von den expertenvorschlägen wird
denn wie schnell umgesetzt werden können
dennoch lässt sich das nicht bis zum
letzten Detail beantworten Priorität
haben offensichtlich erstmal die
dezemberhilfe und die Gras und
strompreisbremse so hat es Olaf Scholz
heute in der Pressekonferenz angekündigt
dass er da erste Schritte schon am
Mittwoch im Kabinett gehen will und dass
er auch auf eine Umsetzung noch im Laufe
dieses Monats hofft allerdings muss man
dann noch abwarten was von den anderen
Vorschlägen noch wann und wie umgesetzt
wird von dieser von der Ampel denn es
sind noch viele Fragen offen ein
härtefallfond oder auch ein Hilfsfonds
für soziale Dienstleister müssten ja
ausgestaltet und auch finanziert werden
bei manchen zentralen Fragen sind die
Bundesländer mitgefragt die können da
mitbestimmen und aus deren Reihen gab es
heute schon erste Reaktionen Daniel
Günther sagte zum Beispiel er möchte
gerne noch eine Konsultation haben vor
der Ministerpräsidenten Konferenz am
Mittwoch Umfragen zu klären also das ist
eine komplexe Aufgabe die die Ampel da
vor sich hat sie soll jetzt schnell
gerechte Entlastungen auf den Weg
bringen die auch noch umsetzbar sind in
der Praxis das hat sie sich fest
vorgenommen aber wie genau das dann im
Detail aussieht das müssen wir noch
abwarten Einordnungen aus Berlin von
Chuck und der la bene die vielen Dank ja
Entlastungen auf der einen Seite
Einsparungen auf der anderen um über den
Winter zu kommen wie voll die
Gasspeicher sind aktuelle Zahlen und
Grafiken dazu in unserer ZDF heute App
teure Energie treibt auch die
Inflationen weiter an in der Eurozone
lag sie im Oktober bei 10,7 Prozent das
ist ein Rekordwert am höchsten lag die
Inflation übrigens in den baltischen
Staaten an der Spitze dort Estland mit
mehr als 22 Prozent
diese Nachricht kam vor gut einer Stunde
aus Essen Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof sucht
Rettung in einem Schutzschirm in
solvenzverfahren einen entsprechenden
Antrag reichte das Unternehmen beim
Amtsgericht ein der letzte große
deutsche warenhauskonzerne stark
angeschlagen die Energiekosten stiegen
außerdem halten sich die Kunden beim
Kaufen zurück wir gehen nach Frankfurt
zur Börse zu Frank Bethmann was bedeutet
dieser Schritt Frank für das Unternehmen
und für die Mitarbeiter insgesamt nichts
Gutes Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof versucht
sich weiter gesund zu schrumpfen dieses
Insolvenzverfahren ist ja nicht das
erste seiner Art bereits im Frühjahr
2020 musste der kaufhauskonzern unter
diesen Insolvenzschutz zusammen bei dem
dem betroffenen Unternehmen ein
gerichtlich bestellter Sachverwalter zur
Seite gestellt wird die Sanierung geht
also weiter wobei der Bund als absolut
wichtigster Gläubiger und
sanierungshelfer dem Konzern bereits
jetzt mit 680 Millionen Euro unter die
Arme gegriffen hat und so lässt Miguel
Mühlenbach der Chef des
warenhauskonzerns auch keinen Zweifel
daran was jetzt ansteht das bestehende
vier Jahren Netz müsse deutlich dies hat
uns vorhin auch noch mal ein
Pressesprecher bestätigt und mindest ein
Drittel reduziert werden da sprechen wir
sicher von 40 bis 50 Filialen die
geschlossen werden müssen auch
betriebsbedingte Kündigungen werden
nicht zu vermeiden sein bereits damals
2020 nach dem ersten
Schutzschirmverfahren verloren tausende
Mitarbeiter ihren Job noch beschäftigt
Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof 17.000
Mitarbeiter doch mit dem heutigen Tag
ist klar dabei wird es nicht bleiben
vielen Dank für die Einschätzung Frank
bebmann aus Frankfurt an der Börse
schauen wir jetzt in eine Region die
sonst nicht so häufig im Fokus deutscher
Politik ist
Zentralasien dort ist Außenministerin
baerbock unterwegs in schwieriger
Mission und die erste Station die
ehemalige Sowjetrepublik Kasachstan
traditionell einer der engsten
Verbündeten Russlands aber eben auch
wichtiger Handelspartner für Deutschland
kasachstan hat was uns fehlt reichlich
Energierohstoffe vor allem bei den
Erneuerbaren will Deutschland mit dem
Land stärker zusammenarbeiten mehr jetzt
von Patricia Wiedemeier
sie hat bei Amtsantritt angekündigt
feministische Außenpolitik zu machen und
egal wo Annalena baerburg trifft sich
mit Frauen diesmal aus der
Energiebranche unter anderem die Vize
Umweltministerin von Kasachstan Energie
es ist das Thema Ihres Besuchs
kasachstan ist reich an erdöl-gas und
seltenen Rohstoffen also genau das was
Europa dringend braucht die
Zusammenarbeit intensivieren näher
zusammenrücken das wollen sowohl
Deutschland als auch Kasachstan
deutsche Investitionen neueste
Technologien kasachische Rohstoffe und
gut ausgebildete Arbeitskräfte sie
schaffen günstige Wirtschaftsbedingungen
eine Win-Win-Situation die EU-Initiative
global Gateway zum Beispiel soll künftig
für eine gemeinsame nachhaltige Zukunft
sorgen
sie wird hier in der Region Projekte vor
hochwertige nachhaltige Infrastruktur
auf den Weg bringen im Bereich digitales
im Bereich Energie aber eben auch im
Bereich Transport hinzukommen soll auch
mehr Zusammenarbeit im Bereich grüner
Wasserstoff Wind und Solarenergie
neben allen wirtschaftlichen Interessen
geht es auch darum einen politisches
Signal zu senden Außenministerin
beerbock will Kasachstan und auch
Usbekistan klar machen Deutschland und
die EU stehen an ihrer Seite sie sind
verlässliche Partner machen fairen
Handel achten Menschenrechte anders als
Russland oder China doch bei allen
positiven Signalen heute aus Astana die
Frage wie weit sich Kasachstan künftig
von Russland lösen wird die blieb
unbeantwortet
wir blicken nach Brasilien zum extrem
engen Ausgang der Stichwahl um das
Präsidentenamt der frühere Amtsinhaber
und Linkspolitiker Lula da Silva hat das
Comeback geschafft aber mit 50,9% der
Stimmen ist sein Vorsprung hauchdünn der
rechtsextrem amtierende Präsident ja
hier bolsonaro kam auf
49,1%. unklar ist weiterhin ob er das
Ergebnis anerkennt Christoph röckerath
berichtet
es sieht nach mehr aus als es ist im
Bundesstaat Moto grosso eine Hochburg
des abgewählten Präsidenten bolsonaro
entzünden Anhänger ein paar
improvisierte Straßenblockaden doch
größere Proteste bleiben aus in der
Nacht nach der Wahl
es ist eine Mischung aus purer Freude
und tiefer Erleichterung die sich
bahnbricht in Rio de Janeiro in dem
Moment in dem klar ist dass Lula das
Silva der Herausforderer von
jay-bolzenario der nächste Präsident
Brasiliens sein wird
es ist wie eine Ekstase weil die
Demokratie wieder auferstanden ist es
ist Schluss damit dass die weißen besser
sind als die schwarzen die Reichen
besser als die armen das Wahlergebnis
ist äußerst knapp am Ende trennen die
beiden Kontrahenten weniger als zwei
Prozentpunkte
Lula wird mit seinem Amtsantritt ein
tief gespaltenes Land übernehmen und so
bemüht er sich auch an der Stunde des
Triumphes um versöhnliche Töne
ab dem 1 Januar 2023 werde ich für alle
215 Millionen Brasilianer regieren und
nicht nur für die die mich gewählt haben
es gibt keine zwei Brasilien
auch ans Ausland richtet Lula eine klare
Botschaft
Brasilien ist bereit seine Führungsrolle
im Kampf gegen den Klimawandel wieder
aufzunehmen seine Natur zu schützen vor
allem den Amazonas Regenwald
für sie half alles beten nichts viele
Anhänger bolzenarus wollen die
Niederlage nicht wahrhaben
Lula hat die Wahl nicht gewonnen diese
Wahl wurde gefälscht
ist bislang abgetaucht keiner weiß wie
er mit dem Ergebnis umgehen wird
für uns in Rio ist Christoph rückgrath
christoph bolzenario hat ja vor der Wahl
angedeutet das Ergebnis möglicherweise
nicht anzuerkennen wonach sieht es jetzt
aktuell aus
ja tatsächlich hat er sich bis jetzt
immer noch nicht geäußert auch wenn der
Druck natürlich auch aus Parteikreisen
auf Infekt endlich sich zu äußern zum
Wahlergebnis ich denke aber dennoch dass
man einigermaßen vorsichtig Entwarnung
geben kann was die schlimmsten
Befürchtungen aus dem Vorfeld der Wahl
angeht in Sachen Gewalt oder sogar eine
möglichen Putsch bis jetzt ist die Lage
hier nämlich zum einen sehr sehr ruhig
zum anderen haben bereits gestern Abend
einige der wichtigsten Verbündeten von
Präsident bolzenario darunter der
mächtige Parlamentspräsident gesagt dass
sie den Sieg Lukas anerkennen hinzu
kommt dass damit dürften sie bolzenario
eben einigermaßen den Wind aus den
Segeln genommen haben hier irgendetwas
größeres anzuzetteln hinzu kommt das mit
Luder ein sehr erfahrener sehr
pragmatischer Politiker gewählt worden
ist der eben auch in der Vergangenheit
schon die unmöglichsten Koalitionen
zustande gebracht hast du das auch eine
gewisse Kontinuität durchaus denkbar ist
was den Politikbetrieb angeht man darf
aber nicht vergessen 58 Millionen
Brasilianer haben wollte zu naro gewählt
und viele dieser Wähler Glauben an
dieses immer wieder wiederholte narrativ
vermutlichem Wahlbetrug und was das für
ein Schaden mittel bis langfristig für
die brasilianische Demokratie bedeuten
könnte das kann man jetzt noch nicht
absehen
danke nach Rio de Janeiro Christoph
röckerath
Kriegstag
250 und auch zu Beginn dieser Woche
bombardierte Russland wieder mehrere
Städte in der Ukraine auch die
Hauptstadt Kiew rund 80% der Wasser- und
Stromversorgung sind nach
Behördenangaben vorübergehend
ausgefallen die ukrainische Regierung
hat den Export von Weizen nach eigenen
Angaben wieder aufgenommen Moskau hatte
das Abkommen am Samstag einseitig
ausgesetzt und den Schritt mit Angriffen
auf russische Kriegsschiffe im Schwarzen
Meer begründet
umkämpft ist vor allem der Süden des
Landes die Ukraine haben sich vorhersson
festgesetzt sie wollen die strategisch
wichtige Hafenstadt zurückerobern
Herr Sonn war im März als einzige
Gebietshauptstadt in russische Hand
gefallen und unsere Reporter daran
Hassan Sade war unterwegs mit der
ukrainischen Armee
wir begleiten die Artillerieeinheit der
59 Brigade die ukrainische Armee steht
kurz vor der Stadt herson warten auf den
Einsatzbefehl der aber jeden Moment
kommen kann das ist ihr Alltag seit
Wochen die Gegenoffensive könnte
schneller verlaufen für Ihren Geschmack
sicherlich geht es nicht so schnell wie
wir es uns wünschen aber wir geben alles
wir kämpfen um unsere Dörfer und Städte
zu befreien will ich dass es schneller
geht ja das will ich
ihre Artillerie ist eine D-20 aus den
70er Jahren eine sowjetproduktion
zuverlässig aber Schwächen in Reichweite
und Präzision
auch die Munition ist ungeschützt
gelagert
wir führen hier gegen offensiven aus das
heißt Artillerie beschießt Artillerie es
ist eine Art Jagd auf Artilleriestellung
wir sind meistens in den Feldern und den
Angriffe und Gegenangriffe verwickelt
ein Katz und Maus Spiel ein tödliches
der Erfolg der gegen Offensive das Leben
der Soldaten jetzt hängt es von zwei
Faktoren ab Geschwindigkeit und
Präzision die Stadt herson ist nur 10 km
von hier entfernt die russischen Linien
gar weniger
nach Abschluss bleiben zwei Minuten dann
könnte der Feind die Stellung
lokalisiert haben und zurückschießen
sie werden noch Sex weitere Salven
Abfeuern von anderen Positionen am Ende
des Einsatzes sei ein russischer Panzer
getroffen worden sagt das ukrainische
Militär
in knapp drei Wochen beginnt die
umstrittene Fußball-WM in Katar am Abend
ist innen und Sportministerin Phaser mit
einer Delegation des Deutschen
Fußball-Bundes in der Hauptstadt Doha
eingetroffen um über Menschenrechte zu
diskutieren zuvor hatte die Ministerin
die Vergabe der WM an Kata kritisiert
und damit für diplomatische
Verstimmungen gesorgt
in Wittenberg haben mehrere rechte
Gruppen zu einer Demonstration unter dem
Motto
reformations-null aufgerufen und 2.500
Menschen zogen am Nachmittag durch die
Lutherstadt in Sachsen Anhalt der
Protest richtet sich nach Angaben der
Veranstalter gegen die Energiepolitik
der Bundesregierung die Inflation und
die corona-maßnahmen zurzeit findet die
Abschlusskundgebung statt nach Angaben
der Polizei ist die Veranstaltung
bislang friedlich
im Protest gegen Missstände in der
Kirche hat der Reformationstag
eigentlich seinen Ursprung diesen
begehen Protestanten heute weltweit in
Wittenberg fanden die feiern am Morgen
in der Schlosskirche statt dort hatte
Martin Luther der Überlieferung nach am
31 oktober 1517 seine 95 Thesen gegen
den Ablasshandel veröffentlicht das war
der Beginn einer Reformbewegung aus der
später die evangelische Kirche
hervorging
zack zum Sport und so Formel 1 und zack
ist ja ein gutes Stichwort für Formel 1
und wir kommen zu einem der nämlich
dieses Sujet dominiert völlig abgefahren
und cool 14 Siege in einem Jahr das hat
Max Verstappen selbst nicht für möglich
gehalten aber mit seinen Triumph beim
Großen Preis von Mexiko markierte er
einen weiteren Rekord hat jetzt schon
einen Saisonerfolg mehr als einst
Michael Schumacher und Sebastian Fett
er ist und bleibt nahezu unantastbar in
dieser Saison Max Verstappen der neue
Sieg Rekordhalter
bis jetzt war es ein außergewöhnliches
Jahr wir genießen es und wollen noch
mehr der 25-Jährige demonstriert gleich
zu Beginn seine Stärke und Überlegenheit
auf dem Kurs in Mexiko der Schlüssel zum
Erfolg die richtige Reifenstrategie erst
so oft an Medium der Zweitplatzierte
Lewis Hamilton wieder einmal ohne
Siegchance verstappens Teamkollege
Sergio Perez komplettiert das Podium die
beiden deutschen Piloten Sebastian
Vettel und Mick Schumacher außerhalb der
Punkte auf Rang 14 bzw 16
durch das 2:1 in letzter Minute gegen
Borussia Mönchengladbach hat Union
Berlin die Tabellenführung in der
Fußball-Bundesliga gesichert ein
Highlight des 12 Spieltages zu sehen
auch online bei ZDF heute.de und in der
ZDF heute App
kaum zu glauben schon zum siebten Mal
feiern die eisernen mit ihren Fans von
der Tabellenspitze auch gegen
Mönchengladbach zeigten sie einmal mehr
dass sie selbst Rückschläge wie das 1:0
der Gäste durch ELVEDI nicht aus der
Bahn bringen der Ausgleich durch Behrens
in der 79 Minute viel spät aber hoch
verdient denkt auch der Trainer
Kompliment und die Mannschaft das hat
mich heute wirklich überzeugt natürlich
gehört dann auch ein bisschen Glück dazu
das Glück nämlich dass mit der letzten
Aktion des Spiels der Niederländer duki
Union Siegtreffer erzielte und die
Berliner damit nicht von sondern an der
Tabellenspitze weiter träumen lässt
ein starkes Signal für den Frauensport
hat der deutsche handballbundgesetz so
würden die Frauen beim EM-Titel gewinnen
die gleiche Prämie erhalten wie die
Männer sechs Tage vor dem Auftaktspiel
gewann die Nationalmannschaft den
Vorletzten Test in Ungarn mit 31 zu 20
am Mittwoch folgt die EM-Generalprobe
dann gegen Rumänien am Samstag ist
EM-Auftakt gegen Polen in Montenegro
Dankeschön und wir wollen noch auf das
Verweisen heute ist nämlich noch auch
Halloween verkleidete Kinder rufen dann
immer Süßes oder Saures und ziehen von
Haustür zur Haustür aber hier in Lübeck
da hat der Hausherr den Spieß umgedreht
lehrt seinerseits die Besucher das
Fürchten in seinem Horror Vorgarten da
stapeln sich die Schrecklichkeiten von
Zombies über monsterspinnen bis hin zu
einer gruselhochzeit na dann happy
Halloween
ja der Oktober geht mild zu Ende und der
november wird das erst einmal übernehmen
allerdings wechselhafter mehr gleich von
Katja horneffer das heute journal um 21
Uhr später mit Christian Sievers haben
Sie noch einen entspannten Montagabend
Dankeschön und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend dieser Oktober war 30
Prozent sonniger als im vierjährigen
klimatologischen Mittel der Jahre 1961
bis 1990 zu erwarten gewesen wäre
deutschlandweit jetzt wird es aber nicht
ganz so nicht weitergehen es kommen
schon neue Regenwolken heran bereits
heute Nacht im Osten ist es dagegen
trocken da bildet sich zum Teil auch mal
Nebel unter den Regenwolken sinken die
Temperaturen auf 15 bis 10 Grad kühler
wird es hier in Sachsen und auch in
Bayern bei 9 bis 6 Grad und für einen
ersten November ist es auch morgen noch
sehr mild bei uns mit 14 Grad an den
Alpen und 20 Grad hier im südlichen
Brandenburg oder auch in Sachsen der
Regen der Nacht zieht morgen Vormittag
weiter ostwärts das wird für die meisten
von uns eher ein trüber Vormittag das
ändert sich am Nachmittag dann regnet es
noch am Alpenrand und hier auch in
Südostbayern für viele wird das aber ein
sonniger Nachmittag ein sonniger
Dienstagnachmittag am Mittwoch geht es
dann Regenschauer und Gewitter in
Norddeutschland am Donnerstag kommt
neuer Regen von besten heran und am
Freitag wird es eine richtig stürmisch
an der Nordsee die Temperaturen liegen
dann nur noch bei 7 bis 40 Grad guten
Abend